The following content is
provided under a creative
commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
JOCELYN: Hi.
Jocelyn here.
Today, we're going to go over
fall 2009 final exam problem
number five.
As always, we're going to start
by reading the question.
The skeletal structure of the
amino acid alanine is given
below as it exists in its
neutral zwitterion.
To the right is shown
its titration
curve in aqueous solution.
The abscissa expresses
concentration in terms of
degree of protonation so
that a value of 0.5--
that the neutral ion is the
only species present.
At a value of zero, alanine is
totally deprotonated and at a
value of one, alanine is
totally protonated.
So let's move to part A.
What is the hybridization
of each of the
three carbons in alanine?
So to begin with this one, I
would start by rewriting the
structure of alanine because as
it's written now, it's not
as clear what the hybridization
of the alpha,
beta and gamma carbons are.
So starting with the
alpha carbon,
connecting the beta carbon--
and here is the gamma carbon--
and of course, we don't want
to forget the amine group.
So this looks fairly similar
to what is on the page, but
I've kind of expanded the
structure so that it's more
straightforward for us to
determine the hybridization.
The alpha carbon is the central
carbon here and we see
that it has four bonds and
four electron domains.
If we go back to the beginning
of the class, we learned that
when you have four electron
domains around a central
carbon, we have Sp3
hybridization.
Going to the beta carbon here,
we see that it also has four
bonds, but one of them is
a double bond to oxygen.
So we need to remember from our
earlier lessons that the
double bond only counts as
one electron domain.
Therefore, this carbon has
three electron domains.
And going back to our
hybridization rules, we know
that this gives us an
Sp2 hybridization.
Lastly, we have our gamma carbon
and it gives us one,
two, three, four bonds and
four electron domains.
Therefore, our gamma is
also Sp3 hybridized.
This problem on the final was
dealing with first beginning
material, but then in part B and
C, we're going to move on
to the material we've learned
more recently.
So moving to part B--
we are now are dealing with the
titration curve that is
given to us.
So this looks hopefully fairly
similar to what is on your
page and the question-- it's
asking us to indicate on the
titration curve--
one, the PKA for protonation
of the zwitterion.
Two, the PKA for deprotonation
And three, the isoelectric
point.
So before we start that, let's
talk a little bit about this
titration curve here.
What is it showing us?
What is it depicting?
What I like to do is--
we see that we have
two buffered regions.
That right off the bat should
tell you that there are two
different equilibriums
going on.
There are two different
protonation/
deprotonation reactions.
So I'm going to split this right
down the middle here.
And that way we can think about
the two protonations/
deprotonations separately.
So on the left side here, we
have the more acidic portion
of our titration curve and
even if you didn't quite
understand his description of
the abscissa, we know that
because this side--
the solution has a lower Ph,
it's going to be dealing with
the more protonated species
of the alanine.
This--
on the right side, we have the
higher Ph, so we're going to
have a more deprotonated
alanine on this side.
And he already told
us that we had the
zwitterion in the middle.
So next to 0.5, we're going to
write a generic term for a
neutral acid.
If we look back to
our structure,
we see that we have--
the neutral zwitterion has one
acidic proton here on the
amine group and it has
a neutral charge.
So that's why I'm going to
depict that zwitterion as HA
Moving to the left, more
acidic portion of the
titration curve, we have--
we know that there's a
protonation going on.
So I'm going to write that as
H2A plus because whenever we
add a proton, we're adding
a positive charge.
And then, at the more basic
side, we have doubly
deprotonated alanine and so we
have just our backbone, which
I'm going to call a and
a negative charge.
So from the question,
we should know that
this is true, correct?
Because he told us that we have
the totally protonated
alanine on the left side.
We have the zwitterion in the
middle at 0.5 and we have the
totally deprotonated
on the right side.
OK.
What else can we know from this
titration curve or what
can we add to it so that
we can understand it
a little bit better?
Well, let's write down the
equilibrium reactions that are
happening that make this
buffer region here.
On left side, we have the doubly
protonated alanine
going to proton plus
the zwitterion.
And that's what's creating
this buffered Ph region.
On the right side here, we
have the zwitterion in
equilibrium with--
again, a proton and the doubly
deprotonated alanine.
These are things that
are true for any
titration curve you see.
Depending upon the number
of protonations--
the number of times a buffer
region might change, but for
each buffered region, you
can always determine an
equilibrium constant that is
causing that stability in Ph.
OK.
Now let's go to the question.
We need to indicate on the curve
the PKA of both this
equilibrium equation and this
equilibrium reaction.
So to do that, we hopefully
will remember the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation
and that gives us a
relationship between the Ph of
the solution and the PKA of
the acid that's in solution.
So writing down the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation--
we have--
not the Ph--
and this is the same equation
that Professor Sadoway derived
in lecture.
And here, I've written it in the
most generic form, but no
matter what our equilibrium
species are, we just know that
we put the more basic species
on top and the acid that got
deprotonated on the bottom.
So for the first point of this,
we are looking for the
PKA of the protonation
of the zwitterion.
So we know that it's an
equilibrium between the doubly
deprotonated and
the zwitterion.
That is the equation
we're looking at.
So let's write down our
Henderson-Hasselbalch for that
and I'm going to call this PK1
just to keep them separate.
Remember here, my Ha is on
top because we have--
our doubly protonated species
is the acid in this case.
Now in order to put on the
titration curve where the PKA
is, we look at the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation
and see that where the Ph equals
the PKA is when the
concentration of the acid and
its conjugate base are
equivalent.
because if Ha equals H2a plus,
the log term goes to zero and
we have our Ph equals PK1.
Going back to the titration
curve, we see that the
concentration between H2a
plus and Ha is equal
right in the middle.
We can assume that this is
a to-scale concentration
abscissa here.
And so there we go up and we can
say, OK, this point on the
titration curve here corresponds
to our PK1.
So from the
Henderson-Hasselbalch
equation, we can see that given
the titration curve,
this is where our PK1 is
and it's about two.
For our purposes, that's--
we weren't asked to estimate it,
but if I had to, I'd say
it's around two.
Now we have to do the same thing
for the other side of
the titration curve.
So if you haven't done that
already, maybe you can stop
now and try that on your own
because it's the same process.
OK.
So it's do of the second one--
which again, is just the Ph is
equal to the PKA when the two
species are equal, except for
now we have different species.
So basically we're
looking for--
our new Henderson-Hasselbalch
equation is--
with using the new equilibrium
reaction, our doubly
deprotonated alanine is now on
top and our zwitterion is on
the bottom.
So this might be a little
confusing because we have the
same species going from the
top to bottom in our
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation,
but remember that
we're always talking about the
acid is in the denominator and
the conjugate base is in
the numerator here.
But either way, we again want
to look for where the Ph
equals the PK2 and so our
zwitterion concentration will
equal our doubly deprotonated
alanine.
And that occurs right here.
So the last part of this
question is to indicate where
the isoelectric point is and the
important thing for this
part of the problem, of course,
is to know what the
isoelectric point meets--
and it's where the dominant
species in the solution is the
neutral zwitterion.
And Professor Sadoway already
told us where that is and it
is where we're at 0.5 here,
which we've already indicated
as where the zwitterion
is dominant.
And so we just can go up here
and circle that and we can
call that number three.
So you didn't have to go through
all of the work I did
and if you were familiar with
the titration curve, you could
have simply put these down, but
understanding where these
points come from is quite
important for understanding
acid base chemistry and
how amino acids work.
All right.
So let's move to part C.
In part C, we're asked to draw
the skeletal structure of
alanine when it is solvated
in an aqueous
solution at extreme acidity--
ie, Ph less than one.
So I'm going to write that down
and then we can go back
to our titration curve and see
where that is because we've
already spend a lot of time
understanding our titration
curve and that tells us a lot
about the acid base chemistry
of alanine.
So at the titration curve, we
see that at a Ph less than
one, we're going to have mostly
our doubly protonated
zwitterion.
That said, now we need to go
back and look at the structure
of alanine and we can put
in the protonation.
So we're given the zwitterion
form of alanine, but at very
low acidity--
sorry-- high acidity, low Ph.
This carboxy group is going
to be protonated.
And so we have both of our
acidic protons are on the
alanine and this would be a
structure of alanine at a Ph
less than one.
Now moving to part D--
we are asked for an aqueous
solution of alanine--
calculate the ratio of the
concentration of neutral
alanine zwitterion to the
concentration of deprotonated
anion when the Ph is 8.091.
So a couple things I
would write down.
Ph equals 8.091 and we are asked
for the ratio of the
concentration of the zwitterion
to the doubly
deprotonated anion.
When we're asked for this,
hopefully you think first,
Henderson-Hasselbalch--
I can use that.
We're given a Ph.
We can find the PKA and we're
asked for the ratio and
concentrations.
So let's write down the
Henderson-Hasselbalch equation again.
And because we're asked for the
ratio, we don't need any
more information except
for the PKA.
Luckily, from part B, we know
what the PKA is of this
equilibrium between the
zwitterion and the doubly
deprotonated anion.
So moving back to your titration
curve, we see that
the PKA is roughly 10--
doesn't need to be our--
our estimation doesn't need to
be exact, but if it's in the
ballpark range, then you
have the right idea.
So I'm going to write that.
We can plug that in
just down here.
Log of our concentration.
That's a log term.
And from here, it's
just algebra.
So simplify a little bit.
If we bring the 10 over to
this side, we get -1.909
equals the log of
a minus over--
I'm sorry.
I'm getting a little
bit crooked here.
And then if you take both sides
of the power of 10,
we'll get--
the ratio equal to this.
And if we take the reciprocal
of this,
we'll get a nicer answer.
We'll get HA over A minus
and it won't be a
fraction over here.
So I suggest that you do that
and you'll see that our final
answer is--
let's put it right here.
81.1:1--
the ratio of our zwitterion to
the doubly deprotonated anion.
And then you've answered all
parts of the problem.